create an emote it's - I mean you need
like Illustrator or Photoshop because
you need to like
design it but anyone can create an email
and send it to me I'll be forever
grateful but it's not wait supreme monk
I've played before he crushed me the
other day I have to take this slightly
seriously my white both games
why was i white both games
as plaque
I'm scared now because I don't know what
to play
trying to remember the game from another
day
I went back in checks that would be
probably unethical I'm gonna play a line
which I'm pretty sure I didn't play
today
just to get something fresh
can i play a special coffin trash-talk
it uh no because he played Bishop b5
when will you be the next chance to play
me on stream sometime in the future all
right for the vague answer probably
sometime this week I've been a bit
sporadic on tuning ass but if you follow
me and you have notifications turned on
you can get a push notification when I
go live I do want to put together a
schedule I just I can't convince
let's play 94
I met Kyle but he did not film that
video by met Kyle in Adelaide it was out
late late some blitz with him I play
them in a blitz tournament
let's do a six
into some sort of theoretical line
Bishop t3 or Bishop e2 are playable here
someone once played this against me and
that was nice I could just win a piece
for 97
website for Mickey emotes you I'm sure
it's possible to make website or emotes
through some sort of like web service
but the professional way to do it is
through Photoshop which I was gonna do
but I'm playing a good player so I'm
gonna hold off for now
uh thanks for the one bit I don't know
where Photoshop is probably the best
option
maybe five
do I play knight c6 first
I play 96 first
it just gives me an additional option if
he decides to take on d4 I can then
choose if I want to capture with neither
pawn b5 will come very soon there should
be seven and then I just want to get
some ideal setup
I can do IRL stream for making emos but
I all stream is just like a webcam like
with the phone right
if I'm making emails I want to be able
to share the screen with Photoshop
now let's try let's try and stay focused
saying focus is difficult
another reason why I don't play too much
classical chasis it's hard to stay
focused when especially when playing
online over the board it's different
I online especially with this chat a b5
no probably not a critical moment I mean
d5 or bishop
he's seven I'm gonna play Bishop e7
I'm not sure if b5 could run into a for
some positional idea but I would be
provoked to overextend just don't want
to deal with that
IRL is when you switch without playing a
game interesting
okay now I have a choice to make
a Patek with pond
so I'm gonna calculate this and it might
be bad and I can hopefully made it spits
if I take with pawn here
pawns attacked I would play Queen b6 he
goes for some f4 plan
f4 is coming pretty soon
regardless
i knowi 5si main idea for him
the thing when they tick with night I
key 5 could already happen
you
it's interesting online tick here and
then d5
he takes on d4 tick tick
wait so take
to d5
was trying to challenge the awkwardness
of his setup and he takes on g4 I take
on d4 Bishop takes e4 pawn take g5
Bishop to g7 or opiates and black is
winning a piece
so that's comforting Oh take 92d five
lazy five I take
by hitting the bishop and if he takes
here I take the bishop so here here here
big dick he's probably watching all of
this to recognizing the flaws my
ovulation take
it's with bishop that's not good
I like this line like t5
see what happens
not sure if that was a full calculation
if it was a full calculation I would
know what he was gonna play here I would
have some idea I actually don't know
what he's gonna play here because I
think if he takes on d4 it just loses a
piece and taking on
d5 just looks pleasant for me maybe
that's the best option for him though
but then I'm happy I like if he takes
and I take I fixed my structure and
ready to play e5 is Bishop will die or
just be depressed Annika is leaving
goodbye study chest lines
and they had 2700 and then crushed me
good luck with that
f-for move that I wasn't expecting
I basically just can part in part to
mentalize all these
like other random moves and this detai
key for line where I just defend my tea
pond
be ok take take bath 6
because now he is threatening e5 which
is a strong positional threats
what else to do I have to tick
you
you
defend the pond in balance position
in Queen 2018 is top 200 good job
this is a very key game if I lose this
game I'll be crushed
emotionally and mentally
but if I win this game
Stream will go on
think about winning or losing I have to
think about the position
a lot of the focus is going to be on
this deep on so if I can basically
stabilize upon it's a nuisance for him
in position
but he already has two attackers he can
remove this night at any time
gassing he's considering some ideas like
this
there might be g3 ideas at some point so
you might want to play d3 himself
probably stop talking though
stop talking uh what about C 3 now C 3
is a move
but III probably reduces attention
so maybe if he plays c3 I just ignore it
on my castle
I'd be interesting
a positional pawn sacrifice g3g 3 is
also interesting
I just don't think I'll place III
because you won't want to deal with all
these like weird lines
but we'll see
chip a3 I didn't see that coming
forgot about this diagonal I can't
castle I could play Bishop you saw them
asked to do a queen 85 as a move
wait a minute d3 III is a tactic attack
this in this maybe he's just sucking the
exchange
that's actually really interesting that
may have been intentional by him I
played e3 he takes I take he takes and
he might have some compensation
I love compensation
I don't want to go for that though
yes
it is a material and I play like f6 in
the end Queen f6 in the end
Ria's Knight c3 saving everything
well that's still interesting okay I'm
gonna go for d3 you take so quickly
I'll take there
weights the worth giving away such a
great bishop
there's a few other moves I can consider
playing first like Queen a5 / Queen b6
check
even 94
you
right so if I take anyone Quinta k1 I
can't play Queen f6 to the Bishop b2 I
have to play f6
qinger seven rickets
do that
I won the artificial castle seems slow
about consolidating minimizing
counterplay
yeah Queen a6 would have been a bad idea
in whatever line
f6i i blanched the queen
my king
as one
I'm also consider like a Singh queenside
Bishop d7 Queen b6 I can't draw arrows
but
you guys got the points
in Queens opponent laughs the game
never be nervous
nervous don't be nervous foreign life
advice
oh yeah this type of position it's
usually it's up to the player who's down
material to prove something
I mean c3 is interesting I wanted to
play Queen a5 but that hangs a queen
due to the ship c6
I'll play king of seven here
you
as why not
someday I'll play Bishop g7 maybe rook
c8
I want to focus on King safety I guess
it's a question can i play rook e8 next
I'm allowed Bishop to gate 7
than g6
it could get kind of weird it's Quincy
for speaking of weird does this move
wants to play f5 is something - my king
what to do
you
maybe six
when a fives a candidate move
really I just want to trade Queens
gee Quinn 85 keeps some initiative
because then I attack this and I attack
this
anytime you plays an i-5 I can either
ignore it or I could plate 95
let's do it
I also open up a square for the rook
useful
six bits four known for new emotes okay
elastically really wants the emotes are
just becoming a sub yesterday
um let's see what I can do if I was
playing a low rated player I would work
on making emotes this game but
but now I have to focus
okay so work to eat it may be playable
so question is can I just take on d2
problem is like my pieces are not
activated yet
but taking out d2 has a really
interesting threat which I want to say
because you might be watching
you
okay let's take on d2
and it's the nights
also hits upon I guess I gave away my
threats plate faster cold with ten bits
I don't have to make new emotes or
emotes more subs you will get and
oh he's saying if I make more email I'll
get more subs maybe that's true but the
emails have to be good enough for people
to sub
so we'll see
elastic hold I thought you had to go you
said by like an hour come maybe you came
back or maybe I was hallucinating I
don't know
there's night a one what does this
comment a one oh he hasn't I see one
that's true I think I would be pretty
pleased if he plays Knight c1
you
unwanted
he plays 94 so I've been holding off on
saying this hidden threats
but maybe now I can disclose that I
wanted to play b5
take advantage of the fact that his
queen
doesn't have too many squares
the 5s a bit complicated though
and I apologize to the viewers but I
have to calculate in silence because
this is not the type of situation I want
to be giving away my thoughts
I will say I'll talk I'll just say okay
I go there
and
so weird situations on up the exchange
okay I see an idea
obviously the the first move on
calculating is b5 so if you always want
to calculate I would encourage you to
calculate and then compare your
calculations with my calculations
there's a pretty critical line after b5
you
you
you
so he twists and turns this variation
you
Australia
you
that's Queen III is also a move I kind
of forgot about
don't know if it does much
wait a minute okay
I have another idea
probably doesn't work
work
just as difficult
like fully involve yourself and still
have no idea what's going on
you
you
I don't think b5 works
just sad that's the truth
sometimes the truth hurts
you
you
our life is not fair
of disappointing
you
up a full rook in opposition
you
I see a draw though I don't want to draw
you
I have another idea
you
I'm gonna play b5 because I see there's
a problem with the line but there's also
a bailout
thank
maybe it's the best move I don't know
see what happens
it's a weird position because I'm
attacking the Queen I completely missed
that move I was I've spent all my time
calculating they take me five
yes that's playable
I do not see neither three
just moved like means somewhere safe
like queen bee too
now queen bee - looks decent queen bee
too
I can breathe easier now does this Queen
house to retreat
so you can somehow
ninja move like Bishop T for it but that
can't work okay so Queen b2
you
the one we trade
my paper should be sudden
I'm just trying to keep my advantage and
consolidates
play this but then I can take as Nike to
in the end
okay stressful game
I can go back and look over this game
because the night ap5 lines were
interesting
I didn't have like a definite conclusion
my name is Joey Conant just left rather
than surrender usually you can claim
victory if your opponent leaves in like
a losing position a chest should detect
that but I guess there might be a flaw
or it just doesn't detect it
okay so now as screen has to move
while she's actually calculating Bishop
d4
but please dance
okay we'll see what happened
you
I'm counting correctly I'm just up the
exchange in this position
see a good thing
I'm up a rook in this position no I'm
out the exchange what am I talking about
I'm realizing Bishop d4 is a candidate
move I don't want to say anything beyond
that because
you have a feeling he's watching there's
probably a way to see if he's watching
right
I forget his twitch name
you're watching
dream something
but I can see everyone who's watching I
just don't know
but his username was
that's too bad
cuz then I would be more free to discuss
my thoughts
Braden Laughlin and the chats with the
Braden emotes look kind of scary emotes
didn't see sting
monkey
is not supreme monk he's just a monkey
there's a difference between a monk and
a monkey I think
you
okay we got two emotes later
he's considering two moves here he's
considering there's a d4 and queen c1
oh I can sit back relax
Riaan knife is here was trying to keep
up with everyone who's been watching
extra kuhar
master cold
hold spamming wait elastic hold
please don't spam
bamming bits are sometimes okay
Oh younger brother okay
it was with great mod it was great
responsibility
okay
my thought is such a
ah
iPod iPod doing work I don't know if
that was intended I'm sorry Hemans if
an iPod I don't even know what night
cockblocks
only been here for two hours it feels
like at least five hours
am I still in 20th place
I was in 20th place or this game
I'm probably not going to stream the
whole tournaments I want to go for a run
today
was raining earlier but now it stops
I never clicked on this image uh Anand
very nice
when was he happy like that okay I'm
gonna go cuz he's thinking I'll go and
show this uh when Aviano was literally
the happiest in his life
it was ultimate moose
the photo is actually a better picture
is it this one or this one I think it is
this one yeah well this is a great
series of photos
Aviano never has been happier I should
have made this one in emo to have a
bunch of like Fabiano laughing emotes
anyway still thinking
I mean I basically know what I'm gonna
do against whatever move that he plays
wait who made that
to the daleks villager do you make this
on on demount
I just assumed it came from somewhere
else oh my gosh I did not consider
Knight e5
is that just winning on the spot
that's terrifying
if you took so long to play it can't be
winning on the spots but it might be
very worst I have King g8
this queen is so attacked
twinning firm it's beautiful all credits
to him
I don't think I can take the nice a file
opening
it's too dangerous
there's no way I can take the night's
so what am i considering if I can't take
the night's any it doesn't make any
sense
I have to play King g8 and hope it
doesn't lose
this is scary
not knowing what he's going to play next
oh my gosh are you serious
if this works
yes and we're gonna end the stream and
I didn't talk down to a supreme monk for
the rest of the day queen g5
that's ridiculous if it works
25
his moves are these moves
you
literally like what he's just done he's
left things attacked by pawns but I
can't take his queen because I get made
laughter somehow look for a way
sacrifice my own queen I have to take
advantage of the fact that I'm up the
exchange and two things are hanging
technically
so the first question to ask is what is
the threat probably just this or this
next question to ask is what do I do
about it
click Queen D for 24 loses material
right Queens e4
idea is if he takes with Bishop than I
take I'm not getting mated right away
and because though
easy
so crazy
do I do i I don't even see Candida moves
I have some sort of counter-attack ID
for
justtake son
it
you
this is so sad
I mean I can't help but just being on
what he's just done
out of this world combination Knight g5
Queen g5 because if he didn't have Queen
d5 like it's probably completely fine
for black
took so long before playing 95
you
okay another weird candidate moves is
Queenie five and even draw arrows I'm so
flustered but then he just takes on c6
doesn't work at all I have to consider
like weird moves here his queen is
hanging
we take b3 now Queenie - doesn't work
if I take his night he takes my night
that's a big problem because in these
frightening maids
you
like I don't even see away it's a fight
here
okay Quincy for the Queen D for his only
move maybe I have to just calculate
actually that a bit more in depth
let's check X with Queen I take my rook
is hanging
not the exchange so it takes on eight
I take here and then he's just up a
piece and pletely winning
you're
work
I can't even move this Queen d8 mate
57
on the move
and what to do
strong
you
I'm is ticking
you
but like really
you
Brooke a7 gets crushed when takes c6
things are hanging threaded the promised
queen jc6 comes with a made threat
I have no time to save the king
you
24
you
you
this is ridiculous
that's so crazy
okay
Quincy for
wait what that's not what I
oh this is also completely winning
take yeah
first I saw him I'm escaping the mates
but now he's his winning material
was that the bus you could have done
probably yes
ah he's still mating me
play rugby aids
nice
you
doesn't even take their book
now he takes it okay
one more move
again
I wasn't really looking at the chat
I was just complete our
vinyl tap chassis a chat Lila will take
over I won't tap just think so oh such a
happy stream a moment ago yeah that took
a turn for the worst
donate all bits of Eric wins well that
didn't happen 14 bits
I'm running I was running out of time
calculator Jones new person
um
I played him yesterday I wasn't
suspicious of engine use but
his strong blitz player though
mouses Ford
[Music]
I mean that's very possible for human
too famous
um
[Music]
25 it's so crazy
it's like a client
a quiet Queen sacrifice who just wants
to take on c6 I'm up material
ridiculous
like this
quickly will stockfish my md5
winning even a bishop to gauge seven we
need for another idea
so no g5 only winning line
Wow
Bishop a3
best of a3 is up there yeah
you take two three this is another
moment I thought Bishop like C take T
three just seems so weird
a pawn structure like this
you
let's do something happy I'm just
curious what the computer thinks of this
game requests
waitwhat
request engine analysis
and someone tell me what's happening
here
why is it not requesting
okay I'm reek
during my windows you can see everything
did I like surpass a limit or something
are there any leeches mods watching or
in the chat that can tell me why it's
not doing like computer analysis as
they're already in existing
confuse me refresh enable I disabled
that's enough the book reenable nope
okay well I'll do this a fancy way
takes a while reload pinch
but the fook Xia is saying there's
already existing analysis
I tried refreshing this is good
opportunity to show a trick in me chess
in this case it's a workaround but let's
say you play a game that is outside li
chess and you want it you want to run
the computer analysis the way to do it
is go to learn study
you study
I'll just computer and then we can
import the game with this ad and then
this better work
these work
okay it looks like it's working
um
just servers which are very expensive to
run at support this feature
remember seeing a talk by t-bolts and
like the the technology that runs this
is very impressive something called
fishnet
you
let's go for here
you
I mean either he's like anonymous like
Nakamura or okay
well that was a slightly unfortunate
experience but I mean the fact that I
have now amazing position to show
students a white to move and win from
this position to find nice g5 and then
Queen d5 and the fact that it just seems
like there's so few options for whites
so thank you to my opponent for he's
having an extract of instructive moments
okay
oh if I want to play more classical
games
bad experiences this tournament actually
three bad experiences one live all
involved in Queen B one another - we're
pretty clear
uhh
[Music]
identify some photos for emotes